Leute sie sind alle loser leona scheer apa/red den aks biegsamen
Des offline uwe und so weiter und so fort ihr mit euren luschen karren ein paar hundert ps
Geben erklären bmw um an das ich nicht lache. Ich mache jetzt mal eine ansage mehr als
10.000 ps
Damit bin ich unterwegs wie was wieso weshalb warum okay ihr sollt nicht dumm sterben hier kommt die auflösung bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Ja super ledersitze steckdosen
panoramafenster mit sonnenblenden
autonomes fahren tabletts an jedem platz elektrische türen zweifarblackierung
Rennerod aufweise bedienung, am platz kaiser café warme speisen ja ich fahre
Siemens ab trans das sind nämlich die hersteller meines neuen gefährts ein icd
3v der fährt nämlich ab dem 10 dezember mit 300 kilometern pro stunde zwischen münchen und berlin in unter vier stunden
Ich war bei der jungfernfahrt dabei hier erreichen wir gerade die
höchstgeschwindigkeit kurz vor erfurt damit ist er locker schneller als das flugzeug zwischen den beiden großstädten mit fahrt zum flughafen
sicherheitskontrolle boarding dem langwierigen
einsteigen sicherheitseinweisung und in münchen dem extra langen und teuren weg zum flughafen bei mir in berlin steige ich direkt vor der
haustüre in u oder s bahn oder in einer regionalbahn und nach einem umstieg dann
Direkt in der münchner innenstadt wieder aus und umgekehrt und das beste
im zug kann nicht schlafen oder arbeiten oder lesen oder filme gucken oder oder oder
Und verplempere nicht meine zeit mit checks und 1000 wegen
Fliegen ist da echt die solche und wer mit der bahncard fährt ist mit 100 prozent ökostrom
unterwegs also viel umweltfreundlicher als mit dem flugzeug und dabei sind die ice3 züge technisch der absolute hammer der ec3 wird nämlich nicht von loks
angetrieben sondern die motoren sind unter den waggons verteilt vier der acht wagen sind angetrieben
dadurch bildet der zug eine feste einheit und ist nicht wie ic züge die durch ein log angetrieben werden nach belieben zusammenstellen
Durch diesen antrieb ergeben sich aber einige vorteile der ec3 hat zum beispiel eine
ziemlich beeindruckende beschleunigung bei der abfahrt fühlt man sich wie in einem auto so flott geht es los der antrieb ist mit 4
500 kilowatt motoren unter den angetriebenen waggons das sind jeweils knapp 700 ps rund doppelt
So stark motorisiert wie die vorgänger damit kann der ec3 sogar steigungen von 40 prozent überwinden deshalb würde auch
ausschließlich zwischen frankfurt und köln eingesetzt weil es auf dieser trasse genau diese steigerung gibt nachteil die ersten ic3 waren ziemlich
seitenwind empfindlich damit sie nicht
Aus den gleisen gedrückt wurden wurden die strecken so gebaut dass sie vom seitenwind geschützt sind wind messgeräte ermitteln
Zusätzlich die ständig die windgeschwindigkeiten und setzten im zweifelsfall die
maximalgeschwindigkeiten auf den trassen nach unten und in den end wagen der zuge wurden
1,5 tonnen
Zusatzgewichte eingebaut aber so oder so müssen ihn ce strecken ganz bestimmte bedingungen erfüllen um so graber umso besser die
spitzengeschwindigkeit von 300 kilometern pro stunde zwischen münchen und berlin die ist nur auf einer ziemlich geraden strecke zu erreichen dementsprechend gibt es auf der
neubautrasse ohne ende tunnel und brücken
29 talbrücken und 22 tunnel sind es genau sogar der meinen also der fluss wurde verlegt und
renaturiert also tiere haben jetzt hier einen deutlich verbesserten
Lebensraum sieht man ja ganz gut und das alles hat die trasse auch extrem teuer gemacht zehn milliarden euro standen
Am schluss auf der rechnung die hälfte war geplant
Ich bin jedenfalls super happy und werde jetzt sicher öfter mal in münchen sein
innerdeutsche flüge gehören damit für mich der vergangenheit an kleine anmerkung noch
zum schluss mein zug in dem ich dann nicht mehr wahr ist übrigens auf der rückfahrt nach münchen liegen geblieben
technische störungen schließlich kam er mit zwei stunden und zehn minuten verspätung in münchen am hauptbahnhof an um
125 hoffen wir mal dass der planmäßige start
Planmäßiger vonstattengeht verspätung gibt es ja bei der bahn leider so regelmäßig dass man fast seine uhr danach stellen kann
paradox hierauf blick so kümmere ich mich öfter solche verkehrsthemen wenn er kein video dazu in zukunft verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er auch kein video hier geht es weiter mit der verkehr der zukunft
Vorbild china dafür drauf klicken extrem spannend was entwickelt wird ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran